nul besoin de partir très loin de paris
pour faire le tour de la france nombreux
l'ont bien compris
tour eiffel ou mont saint-michel 194
milles visiteurs sont venus découvrir
france miniature à elancourt
un chiffre important pour le parc qui
enregistre sa meilleure saison depuis 15
ans grâce à quelques nouveautés fort
boyard est un a été un déclencheur de
visites évident parce qu'il répond à la
demande de nos visiteurs 80 % de
visiteurs sont des familles est
évidemment le jeune public est friand de
cette émission est de pouvoir interagir
avec avec les personnages du forte et
qu' on a agrémenté le parc ces dernières
années de nombreuses animations pour
apporter l'interactivité au circuit de
visite et ça contribue à la revisite ça
donne envie de revivre cette expérience
à versailles également le bilan s'avère
positif 24 % de visiteurs en plus au
château par rapport à 2016 autre domaine
tout autant satisfait le château de
breteuil
ici aussi l'année a été très concluante
nous avons enregistré une hausse
une hausse de la fréquentation d'à peu
près 10% ce qui pour nous est très bon
puisqu'on doit être à peu près dix mille
personnes de plus pour l'ensemble de la
saison jusqu'au 31 juillet pour nous
peut-être la meilleure saison qu'on ait
pu avoir dans les années récentes
de bons résultats qui s'expliquent à
breteuil par les nombreux événements
mise en place en juin juillet et août
mais c'est bien l'ensemble des yvelines
qui a bénéficié de cette reprise après
une année 2016 morose en raison des
attentats de paris et de nice 6 8 % de
fréquentation en plus au premier
semestre 2010 est le déploiement de
volontaires du tourisme notamment à
versailles a contribué à cette
augmentation
500 volontaires avaient été mobilisés
dans toute l'île de france pour informer
les touristes